هاي انا ايمان حسين للي ما يعرفنيش انا
تيتشر هنا
انا جايه هنا النهارده عشان احكي سريعا
الحمله بتاعتي هتقومي تاني انا كان 2018
الحمد لله
2018 انا كان عندي 28 سنه خدت الخبر لوحدي
اتصدمت اللي هو ايه ده
ازاي انا عندي 28 سنه كل الاعلانات على
الكشف المبكر ان هو بعد 40 احنا فين
والاربعين فين بيجي لوحده كل ثمان سيدات
طلعت انا لوحده
فاخدت الصدمه وكنت لسه ببس الصدمه بدات
رحله العلاج حواليا اهلي حواليا اصحابي
الحاجه الحمد لله ربنا كرمني بها اهلي
واصحابي القريبين اللي كانوا مصدومين وكنت
دائما بشوف في عينيهم انت هتبقي كويسه بس
عينيهم دايما بتقول لي
هتوحشينا ازاي الموضوع ده صعب كده كان
الكلام ده كله بشوفه في عينيهم كان صعب
بالنسبه لي قوي بدات رحله العلاج بدات اخد
حاجات وشكلي بيتغير جمالي بيروح واحده
واحده شعري بيقع صحابي بيشوفوني يقعدوا
يقولوا لي لا شكلك حلو لا القرعه هتجنن
عليك ده في موديلز بيطلعوا علشان يبينوا
جمال وجههم بيحلقوا شعرهم خالص يقعدوا
يبعتولي في صور شوفي شكلهم حلو ازاي انا
مش عايزه اسمع كلام فيك انا عندي مرايه
وشايفه انا شايفه ان ده وقت انا واقعه فيه
ده وقت انا عارفه ان انا شكلي دلوقتي وحش
انصاري انا ما اخذتش ههه عشان اقلب قعدوا
يقولوا لي في كومنتس اللي هو انت انت شكلك
حلو بس مش ده اللي انا عايزه اسمعه انا
عايزه اتاكد اني
انا هقوم من اللي انا فيه ده ثاني احنا كل
الباك جراون بتاعتنا اي حد عنده كانسر ده
كان عنده مات ده جاله هو تقيل ومات ده مش
عارف ايه وكل المسلسلات اول ما يجي يكنسل
الدنيا تظلم كله يقع وده هيموت وده بيعمل
ايه حتى اصحابي اللي بقالي سنين ما
بكلمهمش رجعوا يكلموني وبقت نظراتهم كلها
شفقه وحب وفي لينس كتيره مشاعر كثيره
انت هتبقي كويسه بس عينيهم بتقول حاجه
ثانيه خالص مامتي اللي دايما كانت بعد كل
جلسه هي عايزه ترفض الوضع ده اكتر واحده
بتحبني بس كانت بتقول لي كلام انت كويسه
قومي قومي انت هتبقي كويسه كلمه ماما
المشهوره قومي لفي حوالين السفره هتبقي
كويسه بس مش ده اللي انا عايزه اسمعه
الوقت ده انا كل اللي عايزه اسمعه كل اللي
عايزه اشوفه حد كان في وضعي وقال حد كان
في مكاني ورجع يشتغل ثاني انا طبعا كنت
ساعتها شغاله شغلي واقف كان عندي برايفت
بيزنس مش قادره افرد عجينه سكر ولا اعمل
كيكس ولا اعمل اي حاجه كله وقف وقف وقف
كنت بلعب جمب جامد جدا وقفت كل حاجه مش
قادره اشيله مش هحكي تفاصيل عشان طبعا
الاورجينايز هيزعقولي لو حد
تفاصيل انا مش قادره اعملها كله حصل كده
حسيت ان سيستم اللي حواليا كله عمال يطبطب
كله في مشاعر بس ما فيش اكسبيريان صح ما
فيش حاجه تزقني ان انا اقوم انا عايزه
اشوف حد في نفس الوضع اللي انا فيه وبيقول
لي ده انا كنت وانا دلوقتي شغال ده انا
كنت وانا دلوقتي بلعب رياضه انا كنت ورجعت
تاني ابتديت اغير طريقه تفكيري واقول لها
لا لا كل دول بيحبوني اه بس مش ده اللي
انا عايزاه دلوقتي انا عايزه صح انا عايزه
ناس شبهي ما احتاجش ان انا اقعد اوصف
اوجاعي وانا مش محتاجه اوصف اوجاعي هو
الموضوع معروف سيستم معروف بس انت مع
الناس القريبين عايز تقعد كل شويه تقول
لهم انت كويس بس انت مش كويس انت عايز
تصرخ وتعيط بس ما ينفعش تعيط قدامهم فمش
ده السبوتين سيستم صح السبور سيستم صح
اللي بجد انك تروح تدور على الناس اللي
شبهك ابتديت اثرت على ناس
خفوا من كانسر كانسر
دورت على اورجانيزيشن اسمها الجمعيه
المصريه عن مرضى السرطان
دورت عليهم
واتكلمت مع الناس وابتديت اروح لهم حسيت
ان اه الناس دي شبهي الناس دي بتتكلم نفس
البكابلو بتاعي الناس دي بيتكلموا عن
الازمه صحابي عمالين يطبطبوا عليا ويقولوا
لي خليكي لابسه الباروكه لغايه لما يطلع
خليكي ما تصوريش نفسك الصوره دي لما غيرت
فكره ما تصوريش نفسك كثير علشان ما
تفتكريش المنظر ده بس انا جوايا كنت حاسه
انه لا انا محتاجه اسجل اللحظات دي عشان
لما ربنا يكرمني وشعري يرجع ثاني اقول انا
كنت فين وبقيت فين انا اتعرضت لايه وبقيت
ايه كنت دايما حاسه ان هو نفق ضلمه طويل
بس في نور في الاخر انا هوصل لنور ده امتى
مش عارفه انا كنت عايزه امتى دي من الناس
اللي وقفوا بعد ما وقعوا لما ابتديت اتكلم
معهم مع الناس اللي شبهي بيقولوا نفس
بتاعتي اه ما بيناش مش بينا هيستري مش
بيناز مش صحابي اصلا ما اعرفهمش انا قبل
امبارح ما كنتش عارفاهم بس قاعده النهارده
بحكي لهم عن تفاصيل التفاصيل هم بيحكوا لي
اه ده في كذا وفي كذا اه ده هيحصل لك
وهيحصل لك اه انت شعرك هتقصيه مره واحده
انت جريئه ولا زي الناس الثانيه اللي
هيستنوا هو كده كده اخره اسبوعين حبيتي
تبقي جريئه وتقصيه او استنيتي واحده واحده
لغايه لما يقع بلاش تروحي للكوافير عشان
المشاعر
والشفقه بتاعه الناس يشوفك وبتاع بقيت
حاسه اني بتكلم نفس البوكابلو بتاعتهم
وبقيت شايفه قدامي ان هم كانوا واقعين
وقاموا تاني فكنت حاسه هو ده الامل انا مش
عايزه كلام فيك انا عايزه ناس فعلا كانت
واقعه وقامت ثاني
كنت بحضر ساعتها مؤتمرات وندوات عن
الكانسر لان طبعا اللي حواليا هم عايزين
يحوطوا علي جامد مشاعرهم كبيره بالنسبه لي
بس كل همهم ان انا ما اعرفش ايه اللي
هيحصل ما اعرفش الجلطه اللي جايه ممكن
يحصل لي ايه القوالب مهم جدا انا لو عندي
مشكله كبيره لازم اعرف كل مشاكلها اعرف كل
حاجه عشان اعرف احلها ازاي لكن لو دخلت
على الحاجه الناس عماله تخبي المصيبه
الناس عماله تخبي الحاجات عليا انا مامتي
الصيدلانيه فعماله تحاول تخبي ايه اللي
هيحصل لي لما رحت اتكلمت مع ناس فبقينا
نقول الفوكالوريز اللي هي اه ده انت خدتي
الاحمر لسه هتاخذي الابيض شعرك وقع رموشك
وقعت ابتديتي كل شويه يقولوا لي ايه استني
على نفسك شويه دي وقت
ده ربنا مديهولك الست شهور بتوع الكيماوي
دول سكون لا تضغطي على نفسك انك مش
بتشتغلي لا تضغطي على نفسك ان انت مش
عارفه تدخلي دلوقتي قرش ولا تعملي اي حاجه
ده وقت السكون ورقه وقلم
وبدات اعمل ان انا لما اقوم انا هعمل ايه
انا الناس اللي وقفت جنبي
يدعموني وهم اصلا ما يعرفونيش هم بس كانوا
بيوروني نفسهم هم ازاي وقفوا وازاي يشتغل
وازاي رجعوا لحياتهم الطبيعيه بعد سنه بعد
سنتين الحمد لله الحمد لله انا خلصت كيمو
12/1/2009 الها بتاعي في نار سبتمبر
2019 سوري 2019
2019 بتاعي سبتمبر 2019 يعني ثمان شهور
ثمان شهور الحمد لله ورجعت واحده واحده هم
كانوا بيقولوا لي الاستبس خذيها بالراحه
انت مش اخر يوم جلسه هتقدري تنزلي بعدها
مش هتقدري على طول بس خدي وقتك بالراحه
وكل حاجه هترجع رجع تستاب رجعت الشغل رجعت
بدات بيزنس بتاعي ارجعه الحمد لله حسيت ان
انا مديونه لربنا
باللي انا فيه دلوقتي بالوقفه اللي على
رجلي بالناس اللي بتحبني ببيتي الثاني
اللي انا واقفه على الستيج بتاعه دلوقتي
بدات احس انا لازم ارجع ارد الدين لربنا
الناس اللي وقفت معي وهما ما يعرفونيش بس
هم دلوقتي ربنا يديهم الصحه وقفوا على
رجليهم ومش هينفع ارجع لهم الدين ابتديت
احس ان لا انا لازم اعمل حاجه للناس اللي
لسه داخلين على الرحله دلوقتي فعملت حمله
ما اعتقدش ان حد يعرفكوا نفسي ان هي تنتشر
اسمها هتقومي ثاني اي حد يعرف اي حد عنده
برست كانسر انا بكلمه يوصلني بيه اللي
هيقدر صحيا ان احنا ننزل نتقابل بننزل
نتقابل اللي هيقدر نتكلم بس انا ساعات لما
كنت تعبانه ما كنتش بحب ان اصحابي يشوفوني
او ناس بقى لهم كثير ما شافونيش يشوفوني
فيوني من غير رموشي وحواجبي وشكلي تعبان
فنفسيا انا مبضغطش عليهم عايزه نتكلم في
التليفون بس اوكي عايزه ابعت لك صور لان
انا كنت بسمع كلام لما كانوا بيقولوا لي
ما تصوريش نفسك كنت باصور كل لحظه بصور
لما شعري وقع بصور لما طلع واول ما وقفت
كيمو وكله بالتواريخ دي بعد شهر دي بعد
شهرين دي بعد سنه دي بعد اثنين وحاسه ان
انا لازم اعمل كده عشان الناس تشوف يعني
في ناس كده الكونسبت بتاعهم لا داري علشان
ايدي انت قمتي بعد واقعه جامده قوي خليكي
مداريه لا انا حاسه ان انا مجرد ان انا
اوري الناس صورتي اوري الناس انا بقيت
عامله ازاي دلوقتي ده لوحده هيديهم الله
دائما كانت واقعه ودلوقتي بقت كويسه الله
احنا داخلين على النفق المظلم بس هو اخره
نور طويل شويه بس الحمد لله هي وقفت وعملت
12 واحد ده يوم بالنسبه لي قوي او اخر
جلسه كيماوي انا كل سنه بعمل فوتوسيشن يوم
12 واحد
الصوره بتاعه ياسمين غيث دي البنوته اللي
كانت في حلاوه الدنيا المسلسل كانت هي
2017 بتاخد الكيمو عملت المسلسل مسلسل ده
كان سبايرن جدا بالنسبه لي انا شفته 2017
وجالي 2018 لما بقيت عملت لها فولو لما
بقيت اشوف ان هي بتنزل صور وبتعمل
فوتوشاشن وانا خلصت دايو ده سنه ده سنتين
ده ثلاثه بقيت اقول لا انا كل يوم 12 هعمل
وانزل واتصور واعمل دون
ييرز الحمد لله شهر واحد اللي فات
كانتريوس ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله ابقى خلصت كل حاجه عشان هو
كان في شويه حاجات كتير كده كيمو على
راديو على هرمونز
كيمو فري هعمل حفله كبيره جدا ان شاء الله
بص يعني
[ضحك]
وان شاء الله كلكم معزومين فانا مستنيه
بقى فيه هوب لما حاولت نفسي بالصفورتنج
الصح الناس اللي شبهي بجد الناس اللي انا
مش محتاجه اقعد اوصف في اوجاع ما حدش هيحس
بيها لان الناس اللي شبه بعض هم انت مش
انت بس بتقول انا ابني ايدي اتش دي خلاص
انا عارفه بيحصل له وبيحصل له ما بيحصل له
لكن لو جيت لحد ابنه نايم وهادي وساكت
عمره ما هيفهم الازمه لو جه واحد عايز
يعمل
بروجكت بيتكلم مع مع موظف هو مبسوط ان هو
بياخد سيلر اخر الشهر يقعد ويتكلم معاه
وانا هرسكي بفلوسي وانا هعمل ايه ويقعد
يوصف له مهما كان قريب منه بيحب وصاحبه
وهيقول له لا ما حلو السنه دي اخر الشهر
مش هيحس بيه مش هيحس هو قد ايه معاناته ان
هو عايز يعمل مشروع لوحده في اي حد عايز
ياخد
سابوره صح يدور على السبور سيستم اللي
حواليه الناس اللي شبهه احنا مش محتاجين
مشاعر
محتاج ناس مرت بنفس اللي احنا مرينا به
عشان يدونا الخبره الصح عشان يتكلموا معنا
في اوجاعنا من غير ما نبقى بنوجعهم لان
الناس كل ما قربت كل ما كانوا بيحبوك
عياطك ودموعك بيوجعهم انا ساعات كنت بكلم
واحده صاحبتي او بقت صاحبتي يعني كنا
ماشيين مع بعض في نفس الوقت بس انا سابقاه
بخطوه كنت بكلمها تعالي ننزل نتقابل هننزل
نعيط بس احنا هننزل انت تقوليلي انا
موجوعه بايه وانا اقول لك موجوعه بايه
والكافيه حافظنا بيجيب لنا مناديل انتوا
نازلين تعيطوا بس ومش مهم الناس اللي
حوالينا كل اللي حوالينا دول ما حدش عارف
ولا حد احنا هاممنا ان هو يزعل من عياطنا
احنا سايبين الناس اللي بيحبونا في البيت
وبننزل نعيط بره احنا عايزين نطلع الحاجه
دي بره البنت دي كنت انا سابقاها في عز ما
انا كنت واقعه كنت سابقاها فبقيت انا وانا
واقعه بقول لها اه انت فاضل لك كذا انت
هتعملي كذا بقيت حاسه ايه ده هو انا وانا
واقعه كده انا سافوره لحد فلما خلصت قررت
ان انا ان شاء الله اعمل الحمله دي اي حد
اي حد عارف حد داخل على التريب بتاعت
البرست كانسر يوصلوا بيا علشان هي زي شايل
احنا بنوصل بعض انا حد اداني سبورت انا حد
كلمني وقال لي انت
بعتلي صوره انا ما اعرفهاش البنوته دي كنا
بنتكلم بس واتساب بعثت لي صورها هي شعرها
كان عامل ازاي لما كان وقع كان شكلها ازاي
ما كانتش بتقولي انت شكلك حلو دلوقتي هي
كانت بتقول لي اه هو وحش دلوقتي بس هيبقى
حلو بعد شهر بعد شهرين هيبقى احلى بعد سنه
هيبقى احلى فهو ده السابويت سيستم الصح
ودلوقتي لما حد بيقول لي انت حلوه او انت
جميله انا بحس ان الجمال ده منحه من ربنا
ربنا بياخدها وقت ما هو عايز وبيرجعها وقت
ما هو عايز انا قعدت سنه او اكثر انا مش
انا انا شكلي مش هو الناس بتشوفني مش
عارفاني
الجمال ده منحه من ربنا بس الانر بيوتي دي
بتاعتنا احنا احنا اللي بنشتغل عليها